this is a production of Cornell
University
all right well uh good afternoon
everyone
um it's my I am Chris smart if there are
folks that don't know me uh professor of
vegetable pathology in the section of
Plant Pathology and plant microbiology
in sips and it is my pleasure today to
introduce Marjorie Daughtry who is
working towards her PhD degree in
ornamental Plant Pathology
um Marjorie is a senior extension
associate at the Long Island
Horticulture
HR research and Extension Center
um and uh actually they recently
celebrated their 100 year anniversary
and I think
um Marjorie was highlighted in many of
the celebratory activities Audrey got
her uh bachelor's at the College of
William and Mary uh Masters of Science
at the University of Massachusetts she
has re received many accolades uh over
the years has been very involved in the
American phytopathological society where
she served as editor-in-chief as well as
she became a fellow of our society in
2012.
she has also recently received the Cals
award for outstanding accomplishments in
extension and Outreach by an individual
and one of the really cool things that I
am highly envious of is that Marjorie
has a plant pathogen named after her and
there are really very few plant
Pathologists who that have that
distinction and marjorie's pathogen Is
An Almighty which is near and dear to my
heart uh the name is Hilo paranospara
dot tree
is that how you pronounce that Marjorie
that's how I pronounce it but uh you
know for the next Generations people
will probably be mispronouncing it
and as I said there are very few one of
the things that I would like to
highlight uh is in the naming of that it
came out in a paper in 2020 it said this
is dedicated to Marjorie L daughtery who
collected the samples and has made
significant contributions to the field
of ornamental Plant Pathology especially
in the area of downy mildew diseases
which is really cool March has also
given a talk as a person of Distinction
to the American phytopathological
Society at our annual meeting and that
is the video that we will see today
following the video
um there will be a chance for folks to
ask ask questions and then after that
the committee will go into a exam so
with that Marjorie you can start us up
okay great
um I could say some of the same things
but
um Chris said a beautiful introduction
thank you so much and um I did prepare
the video that you're about to see two
years ago in the middle of the pandemic
you'll see how long my hair is and um it
it talks about my career and then I will
invite all of you to talk more with me
about my career after that's finished so
it just leaps right in so let's push go
here hello everyone I'm Marjorie
Daughtry a senior extension associate
with Cornell University and I've been
asked to give a pod talk to you on
learning Plant Pathology one disease at
a time which is how I found it to be I
have a bachelor's degree from the
College of William and Mary and a
masters from UMass Amherst and I've been
working for Cornell University since
1978 here on Long Island the Long Island
Horticultural research and Extension
Center and I do specialize in ornamental
plants or as Christy Palmer would have
me say environmental Horticulture crimes
this is a photograph of the crew here at
the lih rec or lyrec and you will
recognize some of the folks here perhaps
Mark bridge and our director is here
front and center and then mang McGrath
is here in the third row she does the
vegetable pathology here I do the
ornamentals pathology
there was a time when I did not know
that plant diseases existed and I'm sure
this is true for all of the rest of you
as well
uh here's a photograph of me with my
parents back in the early 1950s looking
very innocent that there is such a thing
as plant disease
I was raised in Crozet Virginia in this
house that is nestled at the foot of the
Blue Ridge Mountains they were always
there to look at this is a town that is
very famous for its peaches and it has a
historic marker because the town is
named after the French Railway engineer
who built the first tunnel through the
Blue Ridge Mountains
here's a photo of my grandmother in her
garden uh looking at her chameleon
Wisteria the um grandfathers in my
family were certainly Farmers but the
women in my family have always been
especially oriented towards ornamental
plants
here's a photograph of my Aunt Bobby and
me in her garden about 1956 and again I
think I'm still unaware that there's
such a thing as a plant disease
but eventually we all meet up with one
and you always remember your first for
me it was this one on Azalea it's a
disease called pinkster Gall and it's
caused by exhibition japonicum I met
this disease about 1974 so a good part
of my life had been lived before I even
knew there was such a thing as Plant
Pathology but I looked up those really
curious goals in a book in my aunt's
basement and I was off and running after
that
one of the things that this disease led
me to was a long-term friendship with
Henriette sewer a fantastic lady with a
fantastic Garden called Rocky Hills in
Westchester County and she had many many
wonderful azaleas but she also had the
disease called pinkster gal and I was
happy to be able to teach her that if
she removed the Galls while they were
still green before they turned white as
in this little inset she would be able
to control the disease because the
viscous spores would not have been
produced
so there are many lessons that I've
learned about being a plant pathologist
since I first met the exobicidium and
I'll share some of those with you today
because there are a number of uh School
teachers in my background as well I like
teaching people things
um one is that Sidekicks are essential
uh this is my childhood friend Susan
milias who also went on to a career that
involved science and writing and I'm on
the right here and we had the benefit of
prowling through 40 acres that her
parents owned in Virginia to explore
nature as children and that certainly
fed into my future career
and then in later life I had some
phytopathological Sidekicks uh two of my
favorites are shown here Mary house back
and Anne Chase and you can also see
Larry Barnes there in the background
another fantastic extension pathologist
to work with
Mary I have worked with in many
capacities having to do with research on
Downey mildew and powdery mildew in
particular uh we would meet up at
Society of American florist events and
have plotted a lot of research together
and we're currently continuing to work
on the downy mildew of impatiens today
and here I am with Ann in New York City
and has always said that I make up
things for her to do but I think she
makes up things for me to do and in
reality we come up with projects
together and enjoy doing them together
very much because it's it's just much
more interesting to bounce ideas off of
one another
one of our first projects together was
the book that's shown open here uh which
is the ball field guide to diseases and
that was followed fairly soon after by a
book that we also called Gary Simone in
on which was diseases of annuals and
perennials
since then we've done many trade trade
magazine articles uh including this one
here on ranunculus diseases and we've
always both been very interested in
providing illustrations to help people
identify the problems that they're
facing in the greenhouse industry
our most recent effort was the
compendium of betting plant diseases in
pests which we did with Ray Cloyd and
that's uh still fairly hot off the press
at APS
earlier collaborators included the
Fantastic Rob Wick and Joe Peterson with
whom I did the compendium of flowering
potted plant diseases and we also owe
Bruce Clark for getting us into that
project in the first place
your colleagues really should be your
friends if you can possibly manage that
yes there's some competition but at
least in the ornamentals area we need
one another a lot more than we need to
compete with one another
um here are two of the people that I
think made that easy for me uh first of
all Ron Jones and followed by Mike
Benson there has been this marvelous
ornamentals Workshop held in the
mountains of North Carolina every other
year for quite some time I first went
there to tell them about the Dogwood
anthracnose disease and they laughed at
it and thought of it as a Yankee disease
only to later on find out they needed to
have paid attention unfortunately
but this group of people gets together
um and has a very great sharing time
um with many different projects and
observations being discussed and when
you're with people in a remote facility
and having breakfast lunch and dinner
with them you can really trade a lot of
good information and learn to trust one
another so we've we've developed great
relationships through this particular
Workshop that we've had working for us
as ornamentals pathologists
it's also really important to have
mentors I have only three shown here but
I have many more certainly uh Ralph
Freeman at the upper left was a
phenomenal Extension agent here in
Suffolk County he was the Horticulture
specialist and he taught me everything I
know about extension Jay stipes many of
you know certainly taught me everything
I know about Elm trees but also his
enthusiasm was incredibly infectious so
I'm sure he's given me some of that as
well and Dr Martin C Mathis was one of
my professors at William and Mary and I
learned plant physiology from him and I
also learned the value of a good pun and
also the value of a bad pun as a matter
of fact and he's still sharing those
with me on Facebook today
um it's also very important to have
helpers the people who don't necessarily
travel around the world with you but who
get the work done when you're traveling
around the world
um currently Paulina richlick and Lynn
Hyatt are working for me as research
support Specialists and in the past Yad
Vega and Maria and Barbara and Sue and
Jamie have done terrific jobs for me as
well
Robert Kent is a special person my mate
of many years he's in charge of love and
emotional support as well as advice and
amusement for me and he has certainly
earned the title of Junior plant
pathologist he's absorbed a lot of it
over the years from from hanging out
with me
in egg extension you certainly need a
very supportive industry and I found the
Nursery and Greenhouse Industries to be
extremely good at that they really care
about Plant Pathology and they're
interested in what I have to say
uh you also need like-minded extension
folk because it takes often more than
one person to get a message across or to
plan a meeting and um shown here are
some of the ones that I get to work with
now in New York uh Nora Catlin and Mina
Becerra and Dan gilrane and Betsy lamb
and there are a number of others who
just create great teamwork potential for
us
The Growers themselves are also really
important
um we think of them as perhaps needing
our information but in reality we need
them we want to teach about plant
disease and we need them to really care
about it and I found this to to be a
very nice two-way interaction they have
much to teach me about how they grow
their crop and hopefully I can
occasionally help them when they're
having a small crisis of something
that's a contagious disease
it's also nice to be able to share with
Growers the Triumph of getting a plot
through to the end and having it not
disease ridden you can share the the
fears and then also share the the
Triumph when a control program has
actually worked for a grower
I also think you need diagnosis to learn
by I've done a great deal of diagnosis
over the years and find I'm learning
something if not every day at least
every week just from that constant
exposure to questions of what's going on
with my plant
some of the plant disease eras in my
career have been
interesting along the way and I'll share
some of those with you my masters was
actually not done with ornamental plants
at all the the lab focused on on irwinia
caratoga variety caritabra at that time
and I was looking at the plasmids in
that bacterium under Mark Mound I'm
calling this a cabbage pathology project
because that was where his source of
funding was from later on I found that
soft prod also goes to ornamentals it
certainly goes to poinsettias and
recently we've looked at a dicia disease
that is affecting you getting in
patients
dogwoods came into play very soon after
I moved to Long Island to start my job
in the late 1970s we had a disease that
we called Dogwood lower Branch die back
at first and later on realized was an
anthracnose so Dogwood and dracnose was
named
um
uh and also the pathogen was named on on
my watch discular destructiva was Scott
redland's wonderful name for for the
pathogen and we learned a lot about it
in a short time because it took the
Dogwood by storm
um here we have Craig hibben who was my
research partner in this work
um he and George hudler and I published
together on the disease
um and also I work with Manfred milky
with Forest Service on getting out a
pest alert on the problem and here you
see the naked tree that Craig was quite
famous for in his technicians stripped
all the bark off to show how the cankers
of the disease accumulate on the trunk
this particular disease had a fairly
happy ending in that plant breeders at
the University of Tennessee and also at
Rutgers were able to develop plants that
were relatively resistant to the problem
uh here you see Appalachian joy and
Karen's Appalachian blush which are two
of the Tennessee varieties and you see
Ina there and windham's dog wondering
when someone's going to name a dogwood
after her
geraniums were also a very important
crop in the greenhouse industry during
my early years and the biggest disease
for them was this bacterial blight
disease caused by a xanthamonus it could
cause individual Leaf spots but the
spots could then spread into wedges move
into the vascular system and kill the
plants so it was the most terrifying
thing that a grower would face in my
early years today it's been replaced by
ralstonia solenocirum which is
considered to be the most ferocious
thing that a dream grower can face
because of the possibility of regulatory
Action Against The Race 3 by AVR II type
of that pathogen
the uh just antimonious disease was able
to affect both the IV geranium as you
see at the left there and also perennial
geranium species the hearty geraniums
but there's a big difference in the
symptoms as you go across these
different kinds of geranium the hearty
geranium can be quite a source of
inoculum for the other crops because the
symptoms are very minimal they'll just
have Leaf spots from the hearty geranium
is infected so sharing that kind of
information was what took me to the
international geranium conferences in
State College in Odessa Denmark and I
was also able to work with Steve Namath
and Gary Mormon and Mike slosinski from
Pennsylvania on a feature article that
talked about this particular disease and
how we really need clean stunt to fight
back against it
oh and did I mention that at um cross
nor we always dressed up as our favorite
pathogens and so you could tell what I
was working on by what pathogen I was
wearing in any given year this one is
obviously a xanthamonous cell and you
can see my flagellum unfortunately I
couldn't see so Apple doci who's the
person there in the deer costume was
leading me around all night to make sure
I didn't break my neck
another thing that geraniums are prone
to is pythium root rot and uh so over
the years there have been a number of
people who focused on the pythium and
trying to reduce that in greenhouses
Gary Mormon and San Juan Kim were
involved in the early years and then
Carla garzone at the left there has been
taking up that particular job in recent
years to minimize pythian problems in
greenhouses
possible viruses became very important
from the 1980s on and by this I'm
referring to impatience necrotic spot
virus which was the first one to trouble
the greenhouse industry
um examples of that are at the across
the bottom of this slide and then up at
the top you see three examples of tomato
spotted Wilt virus affecting Greenhouse
crops because actually in recent years
tswv has been more common in the
greenhouses than ins feed they're
they're both thrips vectored and we have
a hard time with rips management and
greenhouses
this also has to some degree got me
around the world because one of the
international symposia on possible
viruses and thrips was held in Taiwan in
1995 and
um also I've had the opportunity to
write about it particularly with the
North Carolina crew again a feature
article talking about possible viruses
as they were moving into and having a
strong effect on the greenhouse industry
in the early 1990s a new problem arose
in poinsettias uh there had never been a
powdery mildew problem in poinsettias
before but it became an instant new
thing and if it had just limited itself
to the foliage it would have been one
thing but it decided that it would move
quite happily into Brax knowing full
well as a fungus that it was just
working on a modified leaf and so we had
a problem that would travel from
production right into
lobbies and schools and churches and
really needed to be controlled from
early in the crop production
so that was a huge effort of extension
uh Jen Hall and I did an article for
grower talks one of the the leading uh
magazines for the greenhouse trade uh to
tell the Growers about the problem
um I worked here with my technician at
the time on evaluating different
fungicidal controls we wrote about this
and other diseases in a article that
Mike Benson put together and recently
um I've done an article
um a chapter in the handbook of Florence
crop diseases that Bob McGovern and Wade
Elmer have been have edited with Ann
Chase talking about all the different
problems that can happen to the
Poinsettia but you'll see here once
again that at crosmore we tend to dress
as whatever pathogen we're working on
there was a herbaceous perennials boom
that came about the turn of the century
as where we look for new crops and uh
Mark Gleason had up headed up a really
interesting effort to put together a
book that held all the information about
the diseases and I was happy to be part
of that project again this is an APS
press book
um about 2004 we started seeing
something new and impatience which had
been a leading crop since the 1960s and
this had a huge impact because first of
all it was hard to identify instead of
having individual spots it tended to
cause very systemic infections that
would stump leaves and make leaves fall
off the plant so for a while there I was
having a challenge in the Diagnostic lab
wondering what these sticks were that
people were mailing to me for diagnosis
um then about 2012 it became perfectly
obvious what it was and it became a huge
problem in the landscape you could see
Coatings of the downy mildew sporulation
on the underside of the leaves and the
newspapers started reporting on it
primarily in 2012 2013 and we found what
a powerful tool for extension and
newspaper can be compared to the efforts
we're ordinarily able to make
um the disease did not respect the plant
whatsoever this is an illustration of
one at my local Panera uh taken on
September 15th and then if you look back
on October 11th the plants have been
just destroyed the leaves have fallen
off flowers have fallen off
um the stems are thinking of falling
over and here in a photograph of Alan
windham's you see stems that have keeled
over and we learned early on that the O
scores that the impatience down in
mildew produces last in the soil to
continue the possibility for infection
in future years this was done largely
through some very meticulous work by
Nana shishka so we knew that plant
breeding was going to be the ultimate
answer and fortunately in the past few
years efforts have been made by the
different plant breeding companies that
have been successful and these three
plants in this image are showing you two
of the previous types of white
impatients that were on the market the
accents and super elephants that are
terribly susceptible to the disease and
then a resistant plant at the bottom
grown in the same trial under the same
conditions with the same inoculum
now we have the beacon series the ball
Pan Am the imera xdr series from
syngenta both of which have eye
resistance to Downey mildew
at about the same time that the
impatients were getting struck by Downey
mildew we had boxwood blight appearing
in the Northeast and in the south on the
east coast of the United States and this
is one of the first plants that was
brought to me a boxwood having a bad
hair day and that's one of its Cardinal
symptoms is the dropping of leaves from
infected plants
there is a leaf spot phase to the
disease and also there are stem cankers
where the pathogen can spoilate
and we found this disease had begun
about 10 years earlier in the UK without
us really being all that aware of it I'm
paying a lot more attention to what
happens in in the EU now because
actually we have so much trade that
problems move around the world very
quickly
we saw when we visited London for a
symposium that the rhs put together a
lot of evidence of the infection in
public plantings on boxwood uh back home
we've certainly seen a lot of problem in
the The Hamptons and in other areas of
Southeastern New York where the disease
tends to cause this defoliation uh under
our fairly wet climate
there's been a lot of effort to do
research on the disease that has been
fairly well funded up till now and has
recently received an scri Grant under
Chuan Hong to to go further but we've
done what we can to learn about the
disease and there will be coming up in
plant Health progress a diagnostic guide
to boxwood blight very very shortly
the latest thing is a disease on Beech
trees this began happening in the
area around Lake County Ohio a number of
years ago and now has spread to affect
us in the eastern part of New York State
there's intravenal banding and also
stunted rugos leaves on the trees and
this has been associated with a nematode
living in the foliage and other
scientists at USDA and in Ohio have been
able to inoculate buds of Beach and
recreate these symptoms these are some
of the nematodes that I pulled out from
foliage that's only about 10 miles from
my office and I fully expect it to be
across the street any day now
my inspiration through much of my career
has been from Cynthia Westcott who was
known as The Plant Doctor she was born
in 1898 and um she studied at Cornell
and that's where her PhD is from she
wrote a fantastic autobiography called
plant doctoring is fun but any of you
would enjoy reading
and she's been much honored she was
called a Horticultural Hero by the Tower
Hill Botanic Garden recently and they
actually named a rose after her I think
this is the greatest of tributes when an
industry recognizes a plant pathologist
by associating her name with something
positive
um I have however recently had a similar
if not quite as nice fate in that cleome
began to show symptoms several years ago
in this area and I shared these symptoms
with some of my friends at Beltsville
and they turned this into a paper and in
the course of working out the fact that
there was a new species of Downey mildew
involved with the cleome symptoms they
decided to name it after me so now I
have the pleasure of knowing that there
is a high low paranoster adultery out
there just as hard to spell and say as
many of the other diseases but when you
run across this disease please think of
me I think it's just fantastic to have
something named after me even if it's
not a rose
so I'll leave you with that and I
understand there might be some questions
afterwards thanks so much for your
attention
uh thank you Marjorie uh if there are
questions you can uh raise your hand and
unmute ask any questions you may have
if you're very shy you could write a
question
Adam
where can I get that xanthamona suit
I do believe that is in my closet
um I also have
um one of my poinsettia powdery mildew
costumes is also available
um and I I don't think I'd even charge a
fee thanks a more serious question you
know and this comes from our our work
together on the Santa monis cannabis
right that you found in poinsettia
um
and you know there are times when uh the
disease origin may be you know uh in
this case it was uh I think Kenya maybe
potentially right were they Ethiopia
close Ethiopia okay yeah right and then
you mentioned the boxwood in in England
um to what extent have you found it have
you found people in countries of origin
for uh you know exotic diseases
um amenable to collaboration
um interesting have there been
restraints that that they face you know
politically or otherwise with their
government in terms of trade
restrictions that sort of tie their
hands or has it always been fairly
smooth
um very interesting question Adam the um
the thing that I have often thought is
that gee it's too bad it's in that
country I don't know anyone there I
don't have a pathologist colleague that
I can just call up and discuss it with
so it is harder for communication
certainly
um there's usually an American company
that is working with any of these more
foreign locations so I generally tend to
connect through whoever the person is
that I know here with the company and
they put me in touch with someone who is
at least a part-time pathologist but
often I feel like there aren't enough
Pathologists on the other side
um and if they're from the Netherlands
they don't like to talk about it they're
very good at keeping their cards close
to their chest
um so there is a A reduced communication
feature that goes with these kinds of
outbreaks that are Global and I think
it's going to be an important challenge
to break that down because there's such
a time delay when you don't have the
ability to talk about what might have
gone wrong from very early in the
process
are there questions
um I'd like to ask a question this is
Dan Marge can you comment on your the
support you provided to Departments of
Ag and other entities outside of
disclosure I mean you mentioned a little
bit about you know the propagator issue
from overseas but comment a little on
that
well that's one of the collaborations
that I didn't give a whole lot of
discussion to because if you want to Be
an Effective extension professional you
don't emphasize a regulatory aspect to
your life because you want trust with
the grower and you want not to betray
that trust and you don't want to be
leading them into some type of serious
quarantine situation uh through any kind
of mistake certainly
um but the reality is that in New York
we don't have a pathologist per se with
our department of Ag and markets so one
of the things that I do in my job is to
serve as their pathologist
for consultation and for training of
their Workforce they have state
Horticultural inspectors that go out
into all the nurseries and greenhouses
periodically and are looking for the
most important and serious problems that
might appear there so um that's one of
the more important educational roles
that I have it's it's one person at a
time when you're talking to a grower but
when you're addressing the entire court
inspector Workforce you're getting
points across to everyone who's out
there as a watchdog and that's that's
really very meaningful so um I've worked
directly with them many times
um over the years and certainly each
time we get a new disease problem uh
that relationship shows back up again uh
recently I was teaching them how to
identify the symptoms of bacterial
blight on geraniums again because that
disease came back for us last year
um and it's it's good to have that
relationship they're very good in the
reverse direction as well they keep me
informed as to what's going on so that's
a very nice working relationship and I I
appreciate it very much
um there are also some things that go
beyond that so that um
I've had a few interactions with the
national plant board or with the um the
Port Authority folks who are examining
material coming in and out of the
country sort of by way of the New York
State uh Department of Ag and markets so
that's that means that things that
um I've gathered such as a good
collection of illustrations of things
like um images of ralstonia on geranium
can be shared with a group of people
whose job it is to be able to identify
it so that's that's been a very useful
part of of my work I think
there's a great question in chat
Marjorie tell me to read it or oh I can
thank you of the most important
recommendations that you would give to a
developing plant pathologist uh
important things that you might have
learned or a culture that you have
observed that needs to be carried on to
Future Generations
well um there are a lot of things that's
that's a lot
um but you know some of them were
emphasized in that video so I'll just
repeat the key things I I'm a real
believer in networking and
um you need to find the people that are
very knowledgeable who can help you
and you need to then give immediately
out to to others who are younger or less
experienced than you uh so it's a very
continuous process
um those kinds of relationships are what
helps me to be more helpful uh for
example people tell me things
um the perspective in that video is
interesting to me for example because it
talks about that long ago disease of
powdery mildew on a poinsettia well a
grower contacted me yesterday with
powdery mildew on a poinsettia I haven't
seen it for 12 or 20 years but it's back
again and without the the interaction it
would just Fester somewhere in some Far
Away County and no one would realize it
until maybe next year it came back much
stronger so um I think anything that
develops lines of communication is
really important for you both in terms
of finding good jobs uh through the
contacts of these other people but also
finding information because each
pathologist has to specialize these days
I'm probably the closest thing to a
generalist you'll ever meet but
um so many of the people that have
helped me in my career have been very
good at bacterial diseases or very good
at virus diseases and
um you know maybe very good at Gerber
problems so I I do find it really
helpful to know the folks who are
specialized in many different areas and
I think just sitting in your own little
laboratory with your own lab bench is
not going to get you as far as as
reaching out participating in APS is one
really wonderful thing too I focus more
on the cross Noor experience in that
video because I was
presenting it at APS so everyone there
uh knew that APS was important but um I
would repeat that your professional
Society is really important uh the
northeast regional Society has been a
fantastic backup for me as well again
because of getting to know the people
and it was the only opportunity I've
really had to go across Commodities I
can spend all my time in ornamentals
ordinarily but in the Northeast Division
I would learn from Dave Rosenberger and
what he knew about apples and
um you know just find out about uh what
Gary Bergstrom had been doing with
userium in in field crops all of these
things end up contributing to your
ability to solve problems which is what
I really do for a living
nice
there's another question in chat keeping
track of current trends is obviously
important but difficult for the
non-pathologist and often by the time we
see in the news it's too late
so are there resources that you would
suggest to Growers and others to stay up
to date with relative uh with relevant
news and outbreaks
uh well Victor I would agree with you
that that's a very hard thing to do
um locally here in Long Island I think
everyone is perhaps a bit spoiled
because there's an extremely active and
functional Cooperative Extension and
they make sure that everybody knows
about new things
um in a more Countrywide fashion in the
greenhouse industry there's a system
known as egro which is a communication
system that puts out information that's
extension information as soon as the
individuals involved find out about it
and have a message for Growers and so a
free subscription to that is a good
example of knowing about plant problems
as soon as someone can tell you what
they really are
um and I I think my simple answer to the
question is probably to be connected to
Cooperative Extension because that is
your main source of that kind of
information a grower probably is going
to learn things from Gossip at their
local
um
supplier of fertilizer and other growing
tools but we don't really have that
grower gossip line we need to have the
communications that flow through
Cooperative Extension and if there isn't
a strong extension where you are Connect
into one in a state that does it well
make sure you're getting their
newsletters make sure you're you're
hearing about things through some sort
of organized academically connected
information source so that it's it's
relevant way above the level of actual
gossip level gossip
it's hard to talk about the new problems
until you understand them a little bit
but once there's been an identification
of a pathogen then um plant Pathologists
can help you understand the the things
that follow from what's known last year
for example there was a virus identified
that is in the tobama virus group and it
was a brand new virus but if you ask the
right people they can to tell you what
to anticipate because they knew it was
in the tobama virus family and those
sorts of connections really help you get
the basics out to Growers fairly quickly
but um I again we're a little bit
blessed in New York with a really strong
extension service I I think we stay
better informed than many
uh Neil has a question that's a great
question about global trade which is
critical to the industry but it brings
in diseases as well oh boy yeah and
that's that's the big question really so
um I'm one of the people who was trained
in an earlier era where
the terminology of clean stock was
considered somewhat sacred this was
developed
um by some of the greats that some of
you folks would know the um Jim tammons
and um Bob ogilvies and kenhurst of of
that era and they learned that you could
take a crop that was not very reliable
like geraniums and you could make it
very reliable by having just a very good
sanitation system built into its
production so that when Growers purchase
cuttings they didn't have to be
terrified about what might be inside
them because they were checked and
double checked there can still be
mistakes even with that kind of a system
but it's a lot better than having a
system where cuttings are taken here and
there and no one checks on them no one
looks to see what's inside them before
they start selling them so um I think
this kind of thing
is the bottom line idea behind what we
need to do with global trade
um the governmental inspection groups
with aphis have set up particularly for
geraniums and really careful inspection
system where they track material from
Individual stock plants all the way
through to the final customer who might
be in the United States so if a problem
arises they can trace it right back and
eliminate the source of the problem and
understand the source of the problem it
does seem to need activity on the part
of our regulatory folks
in the other countries where cuttings
are produced
and that business has become huge as as
Neil's alluding to it's the way we can
have cuttings as propagules because it
would be too expensive to use them if
they were developed in this country with
our labor costs
so there's there's a lot of production
in places where they have standards but
if we go in as American regulatory folks
and say well we have these standards and
they might be a little higher than yours
but if you want to sell to our country
you have to maintain this level of
perfection then I think that will work
um it's certainly necessary when you
have things like viruses where there may
not be any symptom expression at all at
the point when the plants are brought in
you need inspection programs looking for
at least the the most serious problems
we know to date
and I also would advocate for having
some of the old-fashioned methods too
the modern methods of using PCR for
identification for example are superb
when they work but um this goes back to
what Adam was asking about uh when a
company was using PCR to look for the
xanthamon ads they knew about they were
missing a new one
and only by using some of the more
old-fashioned techniques of culturing
for example do you notice a new problem
and gain the ability to to follow up on
it and find out
whether you can control it and all those
important things
so I I'd like to see
um both very efficiently run government
programs that help on the Glo other side
of the globe
along with
um having everyone look for the unknown
at the same time that they look for the
known as I think in modern science we
tend to be so efficient at looking for
the known that we sometimes miss the
unknowns and we're continually finding
new things still
so I'd like to see that combination of
approaches and it's expensive but that
will ensure the quality that will allow
us to keep growers in Business Without
bringing in a lot of bad things all the
time we can't really afford that because
they they lose the crops
that fits I think perfectly Marjorie
into Gillian's question uh which I think
is fantastic that I know there's a bunch
of students online about the importance
of Coke's postulates
um and then and then if you could finish
up by I think I think everyone would
love to hear your thoughts on the
importance the Strategic importance of
having an ornamentals pathologist the
location that you are and just it just
highlight the what we feel is the
critical role that an ornamental
pathologist can play
um here in New York great love to answer
that question and I I like the question
too
would be um first of all the Coke's
postulate question the the quick answer
is
um anytime anyone wants to publish
they'll do Coke's postulates
uh but that's not all the time because
everyone's in a hurry and
um sometimes the people who have the
problem don't have the resources of
agreeing as such as I have and the time
which I don't necessarily have
um to work out the the really distinct
relationship between something you
suspect and the actual cause of symptoms
that you see in a crop
um your average diagnostic laboratory
although a wonderful thing usually does
not stop and do Coke's postulates on uh
any but the most unusual and scary
samples that they might bring in because
it takes time and it takes resources
that they may not have so um I think
it's a rarity but it's very important
and absolutely if you ever expect that a
disease might not be one that you've
heard of before if it doesn't fit the
syndrome that's presented in the
literature
um check into it sequence the pathogen
see if it fits learn more about it
because it it really drives me crazy
when people are sitting on a new problem
and don't realize it and
um accusing the wrong thing of being the
cause is also a large sin so if you
don't do Coke's postulates and ensure
that you're really dealing with the
pathogen you could be getting the answer
wrong
um absolutely so um let me let me go
from that let's see there's one other
question I'll end on Chris's question uh
will metagenomics approaches eventually
replace many General plant pathologists
and the need for diagnosticians who
perform standard diagnostics for known
suspects using PCR based approaches yeah
this is the kind of evolution we're
facing now right
um as a member of the Old Guard I would
like to see some of the basic handle a
plant once in a while do Coke's
postulates every time it looks important
approach rather than purely just looking
at the genetics because I think it's too
big a world out there
and we don't have databases at this
point that are good enough or reliable
enough that we're always going to get
the right answer
through even the very elegant molecular
approaches that we can do today
so I'd like to see us keeping some of
the expertise that is so special that
you find in a Diagnostic lab where
somebody has seen a lot and can apply
their knowledge from previous cases to
the current case and can look at the big
picture and think about well gee maybe
it's just a fertilizer problem we don't
have to find a pathogen here you just
need some of that experiential approach
to diagnosis that will lose if we go
into nothing but what genes are there so
while I I should just give Karen the
floor she'd probably have a lot to say
on this too but um but that's that's my
feeling on it and I I would like to see
Diagnostics evolving where we take
advantage of all the metagenomics
approaches that are available to us but
that we not lose some of the historical
and experiential aspects that I think
are terribly important too
and then
um finally Chris I guess the the I'll go
back to saying we're spoiled here long
island has a lot of ornamentals
producers and they are all very grateful
to us here at lih Rec for what we
provide to them because if they think
they're seeing something unusual they
bring it to us and we diagnose it and if
we need help from other scientists and
other places who might have more of a
genetic approach to working with it
we've been able to find that for them uh
I can take it to melanian and Adam and
beautiful music can be made so the
there's a system here that works so well
for our Growers and they're very they're
top-notch Growers because they wouldn't
be able to function on Long Island if
they weren't it's expensive to grow here
just like it's expensive to live here
so um I think that everyone here sees
how nice it is to produce crops when
you've got a Cornell connection to
understanding what goes wrong when it
goes wrong
um we've got connection to Neil Matson
when we have uh any kind of a a um
abiotic type of problem we've got
connections to John Sanderson and Dan
gilrayne here for entomological things
we've got a lot of different skills
brought into one working unit many of
whom are physically located here and
that works very well for us so um
When I Was preparing
um this talk and just everything I've
done in the past few years I keep
running across names of cornelians and
um there have been so many who
contributed to the knowledge that we
have now
um You Heard Dicky a little while ago
that was Bob Dickey you know we knew Bob
Dickey you know there's there's been
this fantastic tradition of people
contributing to ornamentals pathology
from Cornell and it's a a unique area
because of the wide range of different
plants that it serves but it also is
terribly important because there's a lot
of money in it and many people all over
the United States are involved in the
production and they need answers quickly
they have millions of dollars in their
crops and it's not all written down
because often the crop they're growing
is different from the one they grew last
year so it's a faster moving area of
Agriculture uh than the ones that might
be dealing with soybean problems or corn
problems say so I I'd really like to see
the infrastructure stay at Cornell to
address the problems that affect the
ornamental plants
um and I'm I'm doing everything I can to
to help with that we're we're trying a
bit of an angle of calling it Urban
because yes the people who use
ornamental plants often are the more
urban people
but I think the the core understanding
at the bottom of all that language is
just that we need someone to continue
this great tradition of ornamentals
pathology and I'm going to keep doing it
for a while myself so I'll do what I can
thank you Marjorie and I think to wrap
it up Bill Miller said it brilliantly
not only is Marjorie a National Treasure
but an international treasure as well so
to the committee members uh Neil we know
you're headed off but uh Marjorie and
Mark we will uh hop on zoom on the next
link maybe at 11 20 and Marjorie you'll
hop on that link as well and thank you
so much Marjorie for a wonderful seminar
thank you all for listening so long
thanks Marjorie
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu